好 那個上一周其實有非常多的news flow
整個市場就是根據這個很多news在那裡交易
有一些政治層面 政治層面非常多吧
然後有美國的和美國的一些經濟數據
然後還有就是一些santra bank 就是中央銀行的新聞
其實我們認為就是上一周這種市場
雖然說它那個比較volatile
但是它基本上跟著news flow再走
那麼我今天講一下其實第一個
我對於美國經濟或者是全球經濟的基本面紅觀
其實沒有變化
那麼但是包括Elon Musk和Trump兩個鬧翻
Elon Musk 川普兩個鬧翻
明面上的原因是他的big beautiful bill
就是美國要進行財政擴張
那麼我對財政擴張不光是在美國發生
其實包括有可能 現在已經在歐洲發生
在德國發生 後面在很多國家都會發生
那麼這個事情其實我待會會做一個評價
我覺得是中短期裡面不短期吧
中長期裡面是一個比較大的禮號
而且這件事情上我不覺得Trump做錯
就是說那個財政擴張這件事情
就是大家會擔心對美國債務造成什麼影響
這個事情我其實之前一直反反覆覆講過
美國沒有這樣問題
那個財政擴張或者是財政保持一定的擴張
對於經濟基本面對於增長都是有幫助的
那麼美國的根本的力量也在於它的美元
在於它的household balance sheet
就是私營部門資產負債表
在於它的企業的盈利
這些東西其實我不覺得通過Australia
通過緊縮
能夠讓任何一個國家在財政擴張週期中間走出來
財政擴張週期這件事情本身就有點上癮的
吸毒上癮性的
這個東西要通過增長通過新的技術
然後才有可能走出來
所以在這件事情上我不覺得Trump做錯
雖然我很討厭他
就是他有很多的問題
但是我覺得在財政預算案上
我會對整個財政預算案做一個簡單的分析
先說下整期的news flow
news flow最重要的其實是業經濟數據
就是我們看到美國
其實上週發了能房 payroll
發了那個費用就業
所以我們看到費用就業的headline的數據是比預期還好
但是同時的話
他那個backboard revisit
就是回溯的那個調整的話
我們看到他是slightly weakling
就是小幅的變弱
那麼就是從hard data
從硬數據來看
其實我們看到美國的hard data
是一直在慢慢的往下跑
它跑得速度不是很快
雖然我們看到那個
這個是狗門
就是綜合各方面的經濟數據
我們看到soft data
其實比較明顯在liberation day之後
在美國的那個獨立日之後
隨著關稅政策
隨著市場的這個預期
隨著市場預期
導致的公司企業層
個人層面的消費和公司層面的投資減少
其實它的這個先行的指數
就是已經變弱了
雖然短期裡面就要上週
上週那個consumer confidence
讓它稍微回復了一點
但基本上這個趨勢是往下的
就是soft data
這先行的指數
我們叫軟數據是往下的
硬數據是慢慢往下的
包括我們現在這次看到
能防培若的這個adjustment
然後它後面的數據可能都會往下
但是這次數據同時的話
也告訴大家就是沒有預期的差
就是有一些
就是雖然預期是在12碗
它是13碗adjustment之後再往下一點
但是沒有預期總是有一個
我們叫tell的預期
就是尾部的預期
覺得它可能會變得很差
那麼它沒有走出這種tell的預期
尾部的預期
所以數據整體在這一週來看
是偏正面的
但是不改變它慢慢往下這個趨勢
所以我對於經濟基本面怎麼看
我覺得沒有辦法
基本上還是可能在今年
今年會軟著落
至少會軟著落
明年年初可能是一個低點
這個過程中間會不會GDP變負
會不會變得更差
我覺得有可能
但是不一定
就是dnv就是這個整個往下的趨勢
這個是確定
但是你可以看到S&P的這個狀態
S&P的狀態明顯不是跟經濟數據同步的
S&P的這個狀態明顯是逆向這個經濟數據在走
同時的話
我們看Global全球的股市投資者
Global的Prime Book就是對中基金的投算
你可以看現在已經走到3個CG碼
正的3個CG碼
以月度即是正3個CG碼
這個是比較危險
就是這個當然中間不光是美國
我們看到美國相對來說還不是這個最多的
包括歐洲日本
包括全球的對中基金
我們叫做Prime Book的投資
那麼相對來說5月份肯定是屬於一個超賣的狀態
那麼整體的position
那說5月份為什麼會進入這個超賣
其實和5月份為什麼會進入一個超賣呢
那麼跟3月份和4月份超賣是相關的
因為從reparation day之後
很多的包括real money master
包括HFM其實把很多投資都清掉
那麼現在和很多的SM manager聊的話
反正我身邊的SM manager我就是這樣的
他們並沒有把在reparation day之前的倉位全部買回來
那以我自己為例的
可能我現在私存的倉位
私存不到
那我跌下去的時候
在reparation day之前
其實3月份的時候
其實又傾過一輪
那麼在美國獨立這個之前
其實完全沒有動
下去我也沒有動
很多HFM其實也有點類似
他們可能在發了reparation day的全面的關稅以後
他們做了一大輪清廠
可能沒有我這麼早
但清了
清了之後在底部可能買了一些
但是基本上沒有全部買回來
那麼對中基金現在看什麼東西
其實讓他們可能會回來買
其實他們關注就在三方面
第一個hard data
我們剛剛講的
包括我們看到的能防培若
包括一些其他的這個GDP的數據
還有inflation的數據
這些hard data是不是會變得更差
能不能穩得住
這是第一個問題
那這個數據可能要到年底
或者是大家都知道
不會在現在馬上出來的
所以可能還要繼續觀望
所以這個你說它倉位
確實包括systematic position
這個是systematic position
systematic跟那個基本面沒有關係
是那個量化的這個數據
那量化可能現在是一半
持倉是一半
一半在歷史上
大概是在20%-30%
什麼意思呢
就是大家大部分的時候的持倉
是超過一半
只有在20%的時候
在現在這種倉位
那在hatch fund
在那個smrmage的頭存
大概也跟現在類似
大概在30%-40%的狀態
就是它並沒有
雖然超買了
就是短期裡面
5月份看它買的幅度
肯定是超買
但是從他們持倉來說
並不是那個從歷史
整個統計數據來看
並不是特別高的
那麼也不會馬上取加倉
所以這個又回到我上星期
再上星期
可能一個月前講這件事情
就是現在的position
開始變得更差
沒有像以前那麼好
上周我也覺得position
就是市場倉位來說
變得更加嚴峻一點
基本面估值是偏高的
但是確實沒有達到
去年年底這種
非常危險的狀態
那position會不會繼續改善
繼續改善的空間
沒有那麼大
或者說沒有那麼快
因為大家觀察三件事情
剛剛我忘了
沒有講完
第一個就是hardy的
因數據會不會變好
那這個呢
要到三級度
四級度
甚至民演藝企圖
那才可能確定
第二個就是公司
earning怎麼樣
那這個呢
其實是鼓勵上個月
上個月
或者是接下去
這段時間
市場可能會投資人
會進取一個重要原因
那麼特別
我覺得在Semiconductor的半導體
那下周可能要挖過
對吧
那個Semiconductor半導體
和那個AI包括語音
那這些行業裡面
它的數據
它的盈利數據是非常好的
我們看到包括microsoft
包括一些這個
包括前上次因為的
他們數據就從經濟
就從那個
公司盈利基本面數據的時候
我覺得這還是非常
非常硬的非常solid
經濟哪怕進入衰退不好
那不會影響他們
因為AI的本質是說
token有沒有人用
就銀廠會不會投資
銀廠賺不賺錢
是token
它的那個
那個算力的token有沒有用
算力token
我上次上綜藍
我說過這個事情
utilization非常好
接下去
那他們會不會繼續做KAPEX
那肯定會
雖然KAPEX在今年的
總的KAPEX沒有像去年這麼大
但是今年還要買片嗎
你真的說買片變少
還要到明年
所以說
今年的不是說買片變少
而且買片的那個
growth 增長降環
要到明年
我剛剛講可能不大貼切
那今年的這個買片的數據
可能也會很好
所以這個對於那個半導體
就是硬的盈利的數據
我覺得不會差
這是他們觀察的要點
那第三個就是
tradeo會不會有結論
那中國和美國
這個又回到我們這次
講的一些news flow
上週的時候
他網補又跳出來說
我上次
我記得我上週好像掛了一個tackle
我記得我上週掛了一個tackle
那其實裹不起來嗎
就是他又去跟總書記打電話
所以還說要去訪問那個中國
但是這次電話之後
你會看到中國和美國
雙方的表態其實是不一樣的
這個也造成了
我覺得中間以後可能會有些隱患
那大部分表達不一樣的是這樣
因為國內可能看到
中國的新聞比較多
那麼首先第一個
就是美國方面的對於留學生的表態
是說中國是說留學生的這個事情就
美國在留學生這個事情上網
就是大家達成共識之類的
但是美國是說
希望對名單繼續進行審核的
是留了這樣的一個口的
那麼第二個就是關於臺灣問題
其實臺灣問題
美國是規避沒有去談到這個問題
表態的時候沒有怎麼談到這個問題
所以大家包括對於稀土這件事情
表態也是略有差別
但我知道中國這邊
其實已經把稀土的出口開始放開了
那麼也就是說
其實我覺得雖然說今天可能是
我今天早上沒有看新聞
其實應該現在就是第二輪談判
第二輪談判以後
我們可以關注一下他出來的這個公告
是怎麼樣的
我今天早上沒來得及看
但我覺得哪怕好
後面還是會來來會會有一些波折的
所以整個對於
S Manager資產管理的投資人來說
這三方面的問題
他的理解跟我可能都差不多
就是hard data
我就算現在看上去數據還可以
但是整體的趨勢還是慢慢再往下
那個earning看上去還是不錯的
這個是一個positive證明的東西
但是取決於sector
取決於板塊的
那半導體AI這些板塊低估的
確實之前低估的
而且砸了很兇的
他最後盈利可能還是真的是不錯
但是treatio
大家都會覺得他會來來回回
雖然tackle
但是他也會強硬一下在tackle
就是checking out
就是慫
他會先強硬一下
再慫
強硬一下再慫
所以這個過程當中是
我覺得很難說
資產管理公司會馬上回復到
4月份之前的這個倉位
這個倉位哪怕慢慢恢復
也是需要時間的
所以現在position來說
最多是neutral
或者是偏差
從sysmatic position
從cta
vocontrol
他們來說
接下去的增長
其實至少在短期裡面
一個月裡面不會特別高
不會太好
所以市場處於一個
我覺得是比較
比較糾結的一個狀態
就是整體
從acquity股票來說
估值過高
5月份買的倉位很高
然後整的市場
雖然沒有像12月份
那麼幾種
或者說市場
還有加倉的這個空間
但問題是說加倉的時候
大家還是有很多擔憂
這些擔憂在短期裡面
沒有被辦法被解決
從量化策略的角度來講
量化策略它的頭寸
5月份已經增長很多了
它的這個算法上來說
要繼續這樣增長
也沒有那麼容易
所以處於一個比較糾結的狀態
短期裡面
資金有點壓力
稍微中長期1 2萬月裡面
可能還算可以
但是後面又有一個
衰退的影響在那裡
所以我覺得整體是一個非常
非常混亂
所以非常混亂的情況下
我個人對於倉位的選擇
就是不懂
我也不看著不變
包括我們會講到newsflow裡面
有
比方說上週
大家可能都觀察到這個事情
特朗普和那個
伊隆馬斯克兩個鬧翻
鬧翻以後
其實對於特斯拉這個公司
伊隆雖然回歸公司了
但是特斯拉這個
對於特斯拉這個公司
從總統角度來說
要壓制他的手段還是很多的
那個
比方說補助就是一個部分
對吧
那個特斯拉這個公司
我是一直非常看好
哪怕在現在這種狀態下
包括他跟總統
總統
美國的總統
是不能夠做到
很多其他國家的這個程度的
就是
伊隆以前講過一句話
說
Weas Jack Ma
這件事情在美國是沒法反省的
就是
他不能夠做到
能夠
阿里這樣的影響到
美國總統是很難做到
對這個財團這樣的影響
但是短期裡面的
他的這個壓力還是會很大
那新聞商量
包括現在在
因為美國現在重新開始
就是在包括L.A.
去管那個非法移民
所以在L.A.爆發大規模的
protest
大規模的這個示威
所以你從news flow來說
來講
包括這個公司
和經濟基本面層面來講
他的這個很多
不確定性
還是很大
但是這個不確定性
和我們年初假的
可能會抱一個大雷
不太相同
本質上是鬥局被放棄
就是美國現在
我們一直在講
去年講到
美國為什麼會有一個長牛
這個長牛週期很長
因為美國在走一個財政週期
財政週期的意思就是
和中國2008年很像
貨幣週期遠遠不及財政週期
財政週期對於經濟基本面的影響
對於這個通脹的影響
是立刻建議
但是他從疫情之後
開始走的這個財政週期
才剛剛開始
所以他有沒有基礎
繼續走下去
當然有
可以走行遠行遠
因為整個金融市場的底層
這我一直講到的
整個金融市場的底層是美元
美元底層是美債
所以中間可能會造成的
我們叫Side Effect
副作用是什麼呢
副作用是通脹
通脹而不是美國信用問題
所以我們會經常看到
美國財政週期開始了
所以經濟
他財政週期的第一個
最直接的影響
就是他會改善公司的盈利
會改善公司的profit margin
這個東西都會改善
會增加這個經濟的增長
會增加通脹
這個是比較直接的影響
那麼他的副作用是什麼
就是通脹
所以我們可能會來來或會拉扯
在可能會發生那麼一點點通脹
或者通脹預期再上升
然後搞不好利率要升一升
利率要升一升
壓制通脹
經濟不好了
我再做財政週期
所以是這樣一個過程
你可以記得
2008年的時候
中國利率很高吧
那就是財政週期影響
因為政府要投資
政府要投資他各個城頭
摘牙
然後各個地方的這個
這個大家去造房子
然後資產泡沫的同時
他的利率會上升
那麼在美國的話
資產泡沫
現在已經使的
就利率的這個上升
其實已經使的 risk premium
就 accuracy risk premium
已經是基本上置評變靈了
所以在貨幣週期的時候
我們叫做保值性資產
就比方說比特幣比方說黃金
那這些都是保值性資產
但是在財政週期的時候
是盈利性資產
就是哪家公司有盈利
有增長
你可以回頭看中國08年到15年長
最好是什麼東西
它不一定是保值性的
當然保值性的
要看這個泡沫有多大
那個擴張速度有多快
但是增長性盈利性的
是會跑贏保值性
這是我個人觀點
所以美股
我們去年看到的長牛的基礎
我覺得從美國的
beautiful大美利益法案
我覺得是會有說明它的一個態度
會繼續花錢
那繼續花錢
美國經濟增長很簡單
它的就是信貸增長
我們叫 public sector
and private sector
就是公共部門和私營部門
私營部門幾乎是在百分之二以下
一直在百分之二以下
就是他這一輪疫情之後
從疫情開始
他的增長本身就不是私營部門推動
它部門是公共部門增加快支推動
那現在如果說這個beautiful被通過
beautiful我覺得 likely
很有可能會被通過
那個beautiful被通過繼續去花錢的話
那麼增長就是可以得到保證
但是有個時間差
這個問題我講過
beautiful到人家手上要三月份
所以現在貨油潮可能很多的預期
但是真正的錢到手沒有那麼快
但是從中長期來講
我覺得是個利好
但是在中長期之前
可能會有衰退
各方面的影響
那問題是財政週期不光是在美國發生
那在德國發生了
在中國正在發生
這個中國發生的狀態有點不一樣
因為中國實在私營部門
資產負債表太差了
所以它消費是完全起不來
你們可以看一下
Morgan Stanley最近的一些報告
Morgan Stanley和UBS
可能都做過一個報告
就是關於中國通縮和中國消費能不能成功
簡單來說不可能成功了
他們認為衰退的這個通縮影響還繼續在
那我們也可以看到
中國報經濟數據裡面
中國也報過了
中國報的一些經濟數據
你可以看一下中國每個地方的一些消費的數據
這個基本上都非常的差
那個雖然國家統計局
在國家統計局和地方統計局
對於這些數據
在不停的作假和粉絲
但是你可以看它的一些原始數據
你會覺得這個數據就是稅份還是蠻大
實際情況非常非常差
所以那個中國有點不一樣
但中國也在財政之處
然後韓國選舉選上Democratic Party選上
那麼它的主導思想也是要去這個擴張
所以我們會看到全球範圍內的財政擴張
那和去年年初
我們其實評論過全球範圍內
可能會有這個貨幣的擴張
其實它不但是貨幣的擴張
還有一個財政的擴張
那這個對於資產價格的影響
就在中長期來說
我覺得還是有可能會比較利好
所以我們可以去賭
就是說今年到年底前
或者明年到年中
會不會有人crash讓大家能夠入場
然後會跌很多
我覺得很有可能
但是你從中長期來說
樂觀情緒不會變換
它繼續去印錢
美元會不會崩潰呢
不會的
但是唯一會有影響
是利率可能會變高
看一下30年的利率
30年利率走出的這個區間
這麼長時間的區間
其實背後是什麼
通脹預期
財政的周期
使得對於資金的財政周期影響
兩個一個影響通脹
第二個影響
才對於責群的需求
對於責群需求就地反向
還是要抬高利率
所以在這個過程當中
就是利率偏高是一個趨勢
雖然我講這個事情
中長期和短期來講
雖然我說短期裡面
今年發展沒有那麼大的問題
發展的需求沒有那麼的大
就是相對來說
還是比較平
平穩比去年要少
但是你要放成
這麼長的周期來看的話
那麼我們認為利率
是一個稀稀膚絲的石頭
我們走的
這裡走的是貨幣周期
接下來走的是財政的周期
財政周期裡面
這個趨勢是不太一樣的
那麼
而且這個不光是美國
全球都在走這麼一個周期
那麼關於那個
美國的那個Big Beautiful Bill
我覺得有一個事情
大家要加入關注
然後這個可能對資本市場有負面影響
但是也要看它最後出來的結果怎麼樣
就是Section 899
大家可能聽說過這個事情
Section 899本質上的目標
是說要給對於美國進行懲罰性關稅
就對於懲罰那些對美國徵稅的國家
比方說Digital Service Tax
Digital Service Tax是什麼
就是美國的科技公司
在歐洲經營
在加拿大經營
這些地方都要給你徵稅
所以你徵了美國Multi-International
就美國跨國企業稅
然後還有一些比方說
Undertax Profit Rule
那這些
就是說你在其他地方
就是全球最少
比方說公司要15%的稅
你獲得了更低的稅率
那你在我這裡要補稅
它就可以有權力增加你稅
就是對於全球企業的各種整稅
那全球企業很多都是美國公司
對於美國的企業徵稅
它要進行懲罰性的罰稅
那這件事情是一個雙刃劍
其實對於美國資本市場是極其負面
為什麼呢
你要想
FDI從境外進來的錢
是哪些國家進來的
加拿大
Germany還是德國
然後比方說英國
那這些國家都是被那個section 899
可能會懲罰的國家
所以它反過來做的inplication
做的影響會是什麼
是說它會使這些跨國企業
對美國投資的時候會不會反征稅
然後那個不管是商業稅
它也包括passive income
比方說我在英國是個主體
然後投資過來收稅
也要被收稅
那被收稅就會減少為對美國的投資
這個是肯定的
你知道這個稅收的其實很重的
就是copper tax可以到四年裡面
它是递進的
它四年裡可以到41%
然後明年可以增加5%
然後那個10年的週期有一些
那個比方說only remittent
就是那個我盈利
然後返回去英國
英國公司在美國投資
然後盈利返回去
那這些稅可以增加50%
所以那個它是懲罰性的
但是最後的結果
是反過來對美國投資的減少
所以這個對美國投資的減少
也形成了在比方說短期裡面
或者是中短期裡面
然後我覺得這個東西
政治上的東西很多東西
都是會有變數的
但是在短期裡面會對美國的資金
就是資金會有流出美國的需求
特別在real money
實際公司的層面
我們現在已經看到了
實際的就說我們叫real money
開始對沖美元的風險
舉個例子
Galilian pension房和Danish pension房
就丹麥的這個養老基金
和加拿大的養老基金
他們對於美國的美元的hatch頭寸
現在都在被調整
比方說加拿大的pension
它從32條到26
就是能夠補hatch的部分在調整
所以你會看到這些美元的hatch
在real money上面
已經開始在慢慢發生
那麼大家可能在暑假裡面
沒有看到這麼大的流動性
因為其實hatch房的頭寸基本上還是平的
hatch房沒有家族
但是real money有一個一直在那裏
對沖的狀態的話
其實會給美元一直帶來一些壓力
那這個購物的
這種東西
購物的高盛的美元的估值
但這個東西你只可只能去看一看
它不影響
不一定美元貨幣估值這玩意
不影響貨幣
你只能作為一個參考
稍微看一看
但是就是說
我們會看到
實際上是有一些資金
希望流出美國的
但不太認可去長空美元
因為美元這個東西是這樣的
就是說你雖然看到資金流出美國
資金流出美國
但是一旦流出美國造成一次
金融危機之後
會返向的迅速的全部流回美國
因為是美元本質造成的
就發生金融危機
美元會暴漲
美國發生任何問題
美元也會暴漲
接著就是說
如果說美國利率上升
其實over time
比方說因為美國財政週期開始
美元我剛剛講的利率長長
週期可能會上升
那資金也是會到美國去的
因為你包括看ECB
ECB上一次就是歐中央行
歐中央行上個星期降了25個點
所以在貨幣政策上來說
對比美國和歐洲和其他地方的話
除了日圓
那美國相對來說
還是比較能夠忍痛
就是美聯儲還比較能夠忍
所以雖然有資金流出美國的需求
但是做空美元
我不是很樂觀
如果說一定要去做空的
就我一個多月以前講過的
就是一定要去做空
我建議去做空相對歐洲的
相對亞洲的那些貨幣
而且是買option
不是直接做空
因為亞洲那些貨幣
這些國家相對來說
比較聽美國話
包括日本
台灣這些都比較聽美國話
所以特朗普可能在關稅談判中間
把貨幣加進去
這個是有可能使得你們去做空的
一個機會
這才這個是只能做option
那這個是美元
那最後我說一下比特幣了
那個有不少去問到過比特幣的這個事情
這是Bn的future
就是Bn的那個遠期比特幣遠期的買出
這是過去一年
這個是記錄每一個毫秒
就是每一秒鐘
它的所有的買盤
簡去賣盤
這個是net的
所以你會看到比特幣的future上面
遠期裡面
一直在賣空
持續性的賣空
那這個賣空
這個是右邊左邊單位是比特幣
那個持續性的這個賣空賣在什麼
賣空是什麼比特幣
沒有跌的
因為大家在做對沖盤
所以你會看到右邊的CME的
那個open interest的持倉的數據
會比那個Bn的持倉高很多
但是CME你看它的交易數據
只有Bn大概三分之一
所以你可以認為CME裡面
真正的交易的持倉
只有Bn三分之一
那這個處以三大概是四個別鏈吧
四個別鏈的樣子
那個open interest來說
那個Bn上可能是十多個別鏈
那這個十多個別鏈
這個CME上大概有十多個別鏈
不是交易性的
那它就是買了現貨
在做空期貨
那十多別鏈一百多億
那它的影響是什麼
就是他們買了一百多億的現貨
比特幣
然後做空了一百多億比特幣的期貨
大家都在這麼玩
那現貨的影響和期貨是不對稱的
不是比特幣的信仰
而是比特幣的套利
把這個比特幣的價錢一直在往上推
那麼為什麼你會問
為什麼future上做空
一直能夠有付費率呢
又有證費率呢
因為你比方說
你CME上正常你做空原有
很多人做空
那這個它的這個期貨會變成貼水的
不是深水
那就是幣圈的那些交易所印給的
就硬規定的
它的包括foney rate是硬規定
包括在bn上
它會一直持續的維持比特幣
對應的foney rate
讓整個幣圈的買牌的人
為做空的人付首去費
讓那個做空的付首去費之後
讓華爾街的錢進來買現貨
這個是比特幣這一輪上漲的
本質原因
誰推動的
bn推動的
所以到有一天會不會說大家付不起了
就是韭菜太少了
韭菜沒有辦法再去支持這個費率
然後那這100多億會不會平倉出來
那肯定是要的
就是你一旦沒有funding
它就會平倉出來
但我們要理解比特幣是在漲的
但是比特幣為什麼在漲
是不是因為我們剛剛講的
就是說美元的美國印錢
然後我們進入了財政週期
或者是貨幣週期
然後大家對於比特幣認可
對於储蓄性資產認可
其實不是的
它是現貨和期貨的一個遊戲
有100多億的期貨的做空
然後有100多億的btf
現貨的買路持有性的
然後在那裡持續的推動
但是funding硬血水
也從今年年初可能20左右的水平
一直在漲
現在漲完十幾
然後維持在這個水平上
那隨著利率上升
就比方說利率後面會上升
長大利率在漲
那麼你需要相應的給出
更高的這個funding rate
然後規模變大
你給出的funding rate
給出的錢的成本
你養股一樣養著這些人買
你要養的這個成本也在變高
所以會走到哪一步
我覺得這種遊戲玩下去
可以一直玩
但是沒有一個遊戲可以玩到底的
所以你看看這個遊戲到什麼時候玩完
我們要知道它為什麼會漲
為什麼
就是這個遊戲怎麽玩
這是我個人的一個觀點
我今天可能差不多先講到這裡
然後看看大家你們有些